hello there welcome to Conan O'Brien
needs a friend joined uh by my good
Chums son of obsession Hi how are you
I'm doing all right you're doing fine
I'm doing great okay thanks for
answering for me sure yeah I didn't
really want to know I'm just I'm just
checking a box here keep your eyes
glazed and uh Matt Gourley you're doing
fine aren't you I guess if you say so
but I do okay
people want pep they don't want to hear
about problems I was going to bring up
major grievances today but if you tell
me I'm fine I guess I got nowhere to go
trust me you're fine and quite happy
with your salary all right uh we got to
talk about something today which is uh
actually it's uh it's oh it's a fun
thing it's just different uh it's
something called Conan O'Brien TV are
you familiar with this concept Matt yes
I am okay unfortunately
hahaha
isn't that your dream just more Conan
all the time you're with me every day
making a podcast but then you go home
and you get to relax and instead of
watching one of your Classics on the
Criterion Channel yeah you uh you get to
hear some more Conan but you know a lot
of people would like this I believe that
in my mind I got a new free Channel and
it launches on Wednesday I believe that
in my mind I believe that in my mind
what about your soul Conan I don't have
a soul I have a new free channel that
Launches on Wednesday May 24th and it's
only on Samsung TV plus I do have that I
have a Samsung TV and that's when you
turn it on that's the first thing you
see is Samsung TV plus yes I can't
escape you you can't escape me and you
know what uh most uh polls show that
people don't want to escape me we
weren't in those polls yeah yeah it's
supposed to be we were imprisoned what a
very strange poll to do by the way do
you want to escape Conan O'Brien well
the polling's in anyway to celebrate the
launch of my new channel on Wednesday
May 24th for my New York fans
there's a treat in store for you I'm
gonna
an ice cream truck
roaming around the city that has my face
on it
this by the way was my childhood dream
and you follow Samsung TV Plus on
Instagram or you can follow it on
Twitter or Facebook for live updates on
where to find my ice cream truck and
listen you think that I've gone too far
I have not sir listen to this Jordan
schlantzky oh boy is gonna be in the
truck handing out ice cream pops
Jordan slansky is going to be at the ice
cream truck to meet fans and I think
Jordan has many more fans than I do
people are always stopping me and asking
about Jordan slansky find out for
yourself if he's real because he's going
to be in the ice cream truck
handing out ice cream pops and guess
what the pops are in the shape of me oh
my God you've jumped the shark what is
going on did you make them do this you
know what I did I didn't just jump the
shark uh I got on a motorcycle and and
jumped The Fawns on the show that's how
who is currently jumping who is
currently Jumping the Shark we've gone
that far
and it says right here get your Conan
pop while supplies last
and uh come say hello to Jordan shlansky
my form my associate producer who's
gonna be in an ice cream truck with my
face on it handing out ice cream pops
shaped like me called to celebrate I
want that put into pause on TV plus
popular usage that when you do something
so stupid it's jumping the fonts yes and
you've done it yeah I've done it yeah
Fonz jump the shark now we have uh we
put a shark on a motorcycle and jump The
Fawns very exciting and so check out my
new free Channel May 24th launches
Samsung TV plus ice cream Jordan flansky
ice cream truck
Twitter Facebook listen to the words
coming out of your mouth but
what channel
with all Conan all the time my some of
my best routines and bits from over the
years okay classic Conan Conan okay
we're reviews are you high right now I'm
not high I just you're just like hey
check out my channel and then there's an
ice cream shop what's on your channel
and it says it on this paper and you're
not telling people what's on the channel
listen when you someone says there's
Conan O'Brien on a channel that tends to
be all they need to know
my classic and bits from years of
Performing if there's if there's
anything I've ever done that you've
liked that's going to be on there
there's also popular celebrity
interviews with a-listers look at that
yeah that's cool yeah it's going to
Showcase all kinds of people I'm sorry
I'm selling this better than you are
because you're all about that ice cream
truck I'm telling people what they could
watch on it well you can watch classic
interviews I've done with Jon Hamm Ryan
Reynolds Tom Hanks Tom Cruise Kevin Hart
Will Ferrell
I've interviewed everybody that was ever
born or ever will be born
anyone who's ever lived on earth I've
talked to them and it's all there on
Samsung TV plus but it's all about that
ice cream you better get the ice cream
no this is uniquely curated uh stuff uh
as 30 minute collections of Clips it's
just I mean that's all you should have
to say okay you know it's like a Porsche
it sells itself you know okay I'm a
Porsche you think you're a Porsche just
don't come with Conan O'Brien in the
back seat yeah no I'm not an actual I'm
just saying I'm akin to a portion that
I'm a low slung and packed with power
manufactured in Germany what is low
slung what does that even mean I don't
like that I can't go if you have to go
over a speed bump slowly when you're
driving with me
uh anyway the bottom will fall out
anyway I I think I mean listen to this
this is going to sweep the nation this
is going to be all people we're talking
about yeah and so you know what they're
gonna do anyone who was thinking of
launching a presidential campaign
anytime soon is going to hold off until
this whole Samsung TV Conan Pops in the
shape of Conan Ice Cream Truck Jordan
schlansky thing
calms down and then they're going to
announce you know what I mean can you
imagine DeSantis DeSantis like
announcing during this
and then his people come to him and say
Governor Ron DeSantis no one knows
you're running for president but I told
you to have a goddamn ice cream truck
with my face too late Governor DeSantis
damn it there's already an ice cream
truck out there with Jordan schlansky
DeSantis Jordan schransky nuke Disney
oh